solidarité et désarroi une douleur
inconsolable pour une tragédie que
plusieurs estiment est évitable
rebecca comtois d'orist raout était sa
prairie trois femmes autochtones
assassinés en dix jours à winnipeg un
triste rappel que la violence envers ces
femmes n'a pas cessé c'est un
arrachement shame latente d'une des
victimes peine à contenir sa frustration
et elle a exprimé directement au
ministre du gouvernement trudeau
le manque d'action du gouvernement est
stupéfiant est inacceptable
déplore-t-elle surtout qu'il avait
promis de mettre en oeuvre les 237 appel
à l'action de la commission ottawa
reconnaît que les choses avancent à pas
de tortue ce conte 6 depuis le rapport
si la transformation ne doit pas se
faire à n'importe quel ça doit être une
réponse de façon cyclique le fédéral a
investi des milliards de dollars pour
l'hébergement les refuges et la santé
des femmes autochtones mais le
gouvernement est incapable de démontrer
si ces efforts ont porté fruit et si le
nombre de meurtres a diminué
on n'a pas de chiffres mise à jour par
six parties du défi c'est le fait qu'on
n'a jamais recueilli
les données d'une façon basé sur les
distinctions c'est un membre de
l'association canadienne des femmes
autochtones réclament la création d'un
poste de chien de garde comme le
recommandait la commission pour forcer
ottawa à rester vigilants il faut
vraiment que ce c'est un body mène là
faudrait que ce soit de l'extérieur des
nations unies le canada ne sont pas
capables de se juger eux-mêmes dans ce
dossier doit de la pression s'accentue
sur le gouvernement trudeau pour la
création d'un poste d'ombudsman du droit
des autochtones le gouvernement admet
qu'il n'a pas d' excuses pour son
inaction il plaide la patience une bien
mince consolation pour les familles des
victimes et si christian noël radio
canada ottawa